I know people are going to find this
offensive to some degree the magas will
find this offensive there are a lot of
these folks particularly Trump's
followers that don't know what is
happening and so when they are told hey
you know what I can fix this thing I've
made you afraid of if you just give me
the power to do why I'll protect you
from X if you give me the power to do
why
they don't understand that it's just not
going to happen it's just not gonna I
will protect you from China by passing
tariffs
well but the tariffs are paid by
American come they don't know so they go
yes protect us from China by passing the
tariffs or I will protect you from brown
people raping women and children and
taking your jobs with a wall sure that
yeah sounds like that'll work I will
support you because of that and so
ignorance allows the authoritarianism to
grow and grow and grow